graduated from college,
went to work for Ford Motor Company for several years,
then got a job at the Church of Jesus Christ of Latter Day Saints
and moved back to Salt Lake City.
During that employment, I had the opportunity to be loaned out
to the state's largest homeless shelter
to assist them in developing and improving
their financial and management capabilities.
While there, I became aware of a new approach
to dealing with homeless individuals
and drug addicts.
It was called the harm reduction model,
and it consisted of passing out clean needles and condoms.
And I thought, "Now that is one stupid idea."
(Laughter)
"That's just going to encourage them to continue that behavior.
Just tell them to stop."
Several years later, I read some of the early 10-year plans
to end chronic homelessness
promoted by the federal government.
As I read through those plans, and I thought,
"Pfft! This is unrealistic.
You can't end homelessness.
There's too many personal choices and factors beyond our control."
My perspective changed, however,
when I attended a conference in 2003,
where I learned the reason behind the 10-year plan.
First was this small population of the homeless group
that was 15 percent and were very expensive.
That made sense
for a conservative state like Utah.
The second insight was learning about this Housing First,
or low-barrier housing.
There had been an agency in New York City
that had been inviting mentally ill homeless individuals
to move directly from the street into housing.
And they were also allowed to continue to use drugs and to drink,
just like we can in our homes.
They were, in addition, offered services -- not required to use them --
by on-site case managers
to assist them to adjust to their new living arrangements
and to stabilize their lives.
They were using the harm reduction model.
And despite my initial low expectations about hearing about this model,
they were having an astonishing success rate:
85 percent were still housed after 12 months.
The third insight
was the importance of developing a trusting relationship.
Because of the abuse these individuals have had
throughout most of their lives,
they hardly trust anybody,
and the clean needles and condoms and low-barrier housing
was a means to begin to develop a relationship of trust.
Vital.
So as I flew home from this conference,
sitting in the plane looking out the window,
I realized that my understanding and perspective about homelessness
was shifting.
And as I stared out that window,
this very strong feeling and thought came to me
that if there's any state in the union
that could end chronic homelessness,
it was the state of Utah,
because there's an underlying feeling
and desire and willingness to collaborate to serve our neighbors,
including those who are homeless.
A new vision was becoming clear to me how this could be done.
Now, those of us that attended the conference said,
"Yeah, these models will work in Utah."
But when we got back home, there were many who said,
"Nah, those aren't going to work. They won't succeed here."
But there was, however, an affordable housing organization
who was willing to build our first 100 units.
But they had concerns about having 100 chronically homeless people
in one location.
To address that concern, we decided to create a pilot
to test that idea while we built the first 100 units.
We would use existing units scattered throughout Salt Lake City.
Then we debated:
Should we select fairly high-functioning homeless persons
or the most challenging ones we could find?
And this is where my background on the ranch came into play.
Back then, my mother cooked our meals
and heated the water for our weekly bath
on a wood-burning and coal-burning stove.
And after chopping wood for that stove all those years,
I'd learned to chop the big end of the log first,
when I had the most energy.
We decided to use the "big end of the log first" approach
and selected 17 of the most challenging,
difficult, chronically homeless people we could find,
because we knew we would learn the most from them.
Twenty-two months later,
all 17 were still housed,
including Keta,
who today, 11 years later,
is sleeping in her own bed
and is sober.
At the end of this pilot, one of the young case managers said,
"We used to debate up at our university classes
which theory of case management was the most effective.
Now our theory of case management is:
anything necessary to keep them housed."
We became believers,
and built hundreds of units over those next 10 years,
leading to the reduction of our statewide chronic homeless population
of 91 percent.
Now, who are homeless people?
Many people just want them to go away, to disappear,
not disrupt our lives.
Through this 10-year, 11-year process, I gained many insights
of why people become homeless.
One of those insights came to me a few years ago
when I was visiting with our medical outreach team.
These are our frontline workers
that go out and visit the street homeless and the prostitutes
to check on their medical health.
One of the team members mentioned
that eight of the prostitutes had given birth to 31 children
that had become wards of the state.
They also shared that some of the pimps were their husbands,
and worse yet,
their parents.
These prostitutes,
in their late teens, 20s, early 30s,
were expected to earn enough money a day to support
a hundred-dollar-a-day heroin addiction,
their living expenses
and their pimp.
And with unprotected sex, they were paid more,
and predictably, this would lead to a pregnancy.
Children born under these circumstances many times end up becoming homeless.
And it's not helpful to look at those born under those circumstances,
or a parent that makes their child a drug addict at age seven,
or a generation of babies born through drug addiction,
and not feel some despair.
For me, I believe every person is of value,
no matter who you are.
And it's not helpful to look at somebody with this start in life
and blame them for where they are.
(Applause)
No one grows up saying, "My goal in life is to become homeless."
And that's the beauty of the harm reduction and Housing First model.
It recognizes the complexities of the different factors
that can shape a human life.
These models meet people where they are,
not where we are
or where we think they should be.
The pilot we did with our 17 taught us many lessons.
When people have been living on the street for many years,
moving back into housing
requires lots of things to learn.
And Donald
taught us some of these transition lessons.
His case manager asked him why he had not turned up the heat
in his cold apartment.
Donald said, "How do you do that?"
He was shown how to use a thermostat.
The case manager also observed
that he was heating the beans in the can on the stove,
like he had done over the campfires for many years.
He was shown how to use pots and pans.
We also learned that he had a sister that he had not seen in 25 years,
who thought he was dead.
She was happy to learn otherwise,
and they were soon reconnected.
Hundreds of people like Keta and Donald are now housed
and reconnecting with their families.
Also, many of our communities are incurring
fewer emergency services costs.
I have learned over and over again
that when you listen to somebody's story with an open heart,
walk in their shoes with them,
you can't help but love and care for them
and want to serve them.
This is why I'm committed
to continuing to bring hope and support to our homeless citizens,
who I consider to be my brothers and sisters.
Thank you.
(Applause)